بضعه ايام على تولي الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الجديده مهامها كانت كافيه لتنفذ استفزازا
واضحا لمشاعر المقدسيين وتنتهي كالوضع
القائمه في القدس المحتله
فالمقدسات الاسلاميه ومواقع مسيحيه كانت
مجددا تحت وطاه انتهاكات الاحتلال ومع
تولي حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو الاكثر تطرفا
وقربا من التيار اليمني المتشدد في
اسرائيل مقاليد الحكم
كثير وزير الامن القومي الجديد لم يختلف
نهجه عن ما كان عليه قبل توليه الوزاره
يجول في حرم المسجد الاقصى المبارك دون
رابع وبحمايه الشرطه الاسرائيليه
خطوه لم يعترض عليها نتانيا
وذهب المتحدث باسمه للقول ان اقتحام بكثير
للاقصى لا يشكل تغيرا للوضع القائم في
الاماكن المقدسه واضاف انما سماها زياره
تاتي ضمن اجراءات الوضع القائم بالفعل
بحيث يسمح لليهود بزياره الاقصى الذي
نعتبره جبل الهيكل اقدس مكان لديانه
اليهوديه على حد زعمه ترفق اقتحام ابن
كثير قيام مستوطنين بتنفيذ عمليات تخريب
لمقبره الكنيسه الانجيليه في القدس
المحتله لكن الانتهاكات لم تبدا مع
الحكومه المتطرفه الاحدث في اسرائيل ولن
تنتهي معها على الاغلب
فاقتحم اكثر من 48 الف متطرف الاقصى
المبارك عام 2022 وحده واعتقلت قوات
الاحتلال نحو ثلاثه الاف فلسطينيين في
المدينه العام الماضي